edouard husson bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de hervé n'était france et
dernière visite protocolaire donc dans
gala merkel comme chancelière
d'allemagne elle va recevoir les
insignes de la grand croix de la légion
d'honneur des mains des manuels macro on
disait qu'elle est là la portée
politique de cette rencontre le message
envoyé à l'europe
écoutez
moi je suis très sceptique je dirais pas
choquer dans la mesure où je pense que
je vais dire le contraire de ce que tout
le monde dit je pense que qu'angela
merkel d'abord n'a pas été un bon
chancelier pour l'allemagne et d'autre
part a beaucoup abîmé la relation franco
allemande c'est pourquoi je ne comprends
pas bien le sens de cette légion
d'honneur puis c'est pas rien grand
croix de la légion d'honneur
alors je vous donne quelques exemples la
sortie abrupte du nucléaire sans
concertation avec la france qui a
complètement déséquilibré la notion
d'autonomie énergétique de l'europe
autre exemple la crise ukrainienne
françois hollande on dit pas souvent du
bien lui mais il avait il a négocié au
départ c'est lui qui a lancé les accords
de minsk angela merkel n'a rien fait
pour qu'il soit vraiment appliquée
ensuite le break site en gala merkel
était en position d'arriver à un accord
beaucoup plus favorables à l'union
européenne avec la grande bretagne elle
ne l'a pas fait la crise des migrants où
elle a de manière unilatérale le mil
europe devant le fait accompli et tout
ça je pense que ce sont deux c'était des
raisons de ne pas de ne pas honorer
angela merkel comme on l'a fait pour des
chanceliers précédent à qui
effectivement la france doit beaucoup
comme garage schröder comme helmut kohl
ou comme ou comme vie libre en toi des
noirs donc moi même je suis très
sceptique sur ce choix fait par le le
président macron 2
d'honorer à ce point la chancelière
allemande sortante alors concernant leur
relation justement mai 2010 neuf dans un
quotidien allemand anglais la mère
qu'elle avait reconnu des divergences
avec le président français l'avait
souligné les différences de mentalité
entre autres des différences dans leur
compréhension des rôles sur quel point
leur vision était opposé et finalement
alors si vous voulez je pense qu'en fait
idéologiquement les deux sont très
proches
angela merkel a inventé le en même temps
des années avant emmanuel macron elle a
voulu gouverner au centre gauche comme
emmanuel macron et donc je pense que
leur leur vision sont extrêmement
proches en revanche la question pour un
président français celui-là défi de la
défense des intérêts de son pays et le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
emmanuel macron à a profité de la la
bienveillance dans gala merkel depuis la
crise du duduk au vide pour endetter un
peu plus la france est aujourd'hui c'est
celle allemagne ce sont les les taux
d'intérêt allemands qui qui garantisse
la dette française donc on a un pacte
d'intérêt mais qui n'est pas un avantage
de notre pays je donne l exemple
énergétique jeu prenons l'exemple de la
défense européenne les années les années
trump ont été des années où on aurait pu
avancer quoi qu'on pense du président
américain de l'époque on aurait pu
avancer pour plus d'autonomie européenne
en fait tanguer la merkel n'en a rien
fait donc si vous voulez jeu qu'on a le
paradoxe de d'un chancelier et d'un
président français qui s'entendent bien
et qui sont très proches idéologiquement
mais
autant les intérêts allemands et les
intérêts français ont divergé parce que
finalement il n'ya que l'accord sur le
plan de la relance européenne consigner
les les deux chefs d'état
oui alors si il ya eu le traité d'aix la
chapelle mais qui est plus en début 2019
mais qui est qui et plus qui est plus
finalement une série de voeux pieux il
ya une il ya une invention assez bonne
de ce traité c'est le
c'est effectivement
l'assemblée parlementaire franco
allemande qui pourrait permettre à la
france de mieux connaître la classe
politique allemande est de mieux négocié
en amont ce qu'elle veut obtenir de
l'allemagne donc sur ce point là on a
fait de petites avancées mais ce sont
des progrès très modeste est
effectivement comme le sous-entend votre
question sur le sujet d'une d'un budget
de la zone euro par exemple angela
merkel avait fait la sourde oreille
c'est uniquement la crise sanitaire qui
a fait qu'on a eu un accord européen
mais aller à l'échelle de l'union
européenne angela merkel si vous voulez
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a jamais fait
aucune concession à la france
rappelez-vous l'union pour la
méditerranée de nicolas sarkozy est bien
bon sarkozy avait sans doute mal négocié
mais l'allemagne a dit non à l'époque et
ça ne s'est pas fait donc si vous voulez
je le répète je ne vois pas pourquoi on
remettrait le grand la grand croix de la
légion d'honneur à angela merkel il ya
vraiment aucune raison en tout cas
angela merkel qui va quitter le pouvoir
la france qui dans quelques mois va
prendre la présidence de l'ue eux
quelles conséquences à la fois le départ
d'angela merkel cette présidence
française à la tête de l'union
européenne quelles conséquences sur le
couple franco allemand est ce que il va
devenir déséquilibré et finalement
non écoutez je je pense paradoxalement
que c'est une chance parce que angela
merkel si vous voulez prude et rarement
positions sur les sujets elle laissait
d'autres se faire pour elle c'est une
très difficile pour les présidents
français d'avancé d'avancé avec elle
alors que là on va avoir une coalition
de trois partis en allemagne et ses
trois parties vont avoir à négocier
âprement entre eux d intérêt et sait
c'est une chance pour la france parce
que si nous savons
lire dans le jeu politique allemand si
par exemple nous exploitons bien je le
disais tout à l'heure l'assemblée
parlementaire franco allemande si nous
tissons des liens en dessous des
gouvernements c'est extrêmement
important la vie politique allemand ne
se décide pas seulement à berlin elle se
décide elle se décide aussi dans les
länder elle se décide aussi au bundestag
elle se décide aussi à bruxelles où les
où les allemands de bruxelles sont
extrêmement puissants parce qu'ils
pensent qu'ils font leur travail tout
simplement à la différence des
parlementaires français et est donc je
dirais que si on sait faire on aura des
partenaires qui seront beaucoup plus
franc beaucoup plus direct et en même
temps qu'ils auront souvent besoin de
nous pour les aider à trancher dans
certains de leurs arbitrages interne
donc olaf scholz peut-être une chance et
on disait je voyais dans votre reportage
tout à l'heure christiane liner mais
écoutez il ya un énorme avantage
qu'étienne lieners au moins il dit ce
qu'il pense ça n'a jamais été le cas
dans des lames aircal merci beaucoup et
edouard husson d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes historien ainsi avons
également spécialiste de l'allemagne
[Musique]